one of the things that I love best about
mathematics and I know mr. sleaze is
very similar because when I get excited
about learning or teaching something and
I show mrs. Lee she gets the same
excited face that I do is that
mathematics is hugely intertwined like a
good story you know where you're like ah
this plotline is coming over here and
you don't expect it has any connection
but then it's like oh it don't make
sense right now this topic within
mathematics is one of the most
intertwined which is really saying
something okay so when we put this table
together
you might recall I was trying to focus
your attention really on think about
concavity and its relationship to the
first derivative but hopefully it did
not escape your attention but here in
this I'll highlight it for you sorry
it's very dark I can't say here in this
middle rod let's pick an appropriate
color like this right in here right
there's some things that we've been
dealing with already over the past like
a couple of weeks you're like wait a
second we know about these shapes and we
have dealt with them way before we
introduced the second derivative concave
and all that kind of thing now the
implication of this is everything that
we know about these things fits like a
really snug jigsaw piece puzzle into
what we were looking at with the first
derivative and trying to determine
stationary points there's a whole other
path to determine what kind of
stationary point you have that doesn't
have to do with the first derivative it
has to do with the second okay so what
I'd like you to do now is remember about
a week ago I gave you this enormous flow
chart do you remember that and it's like
a big mess and then we sort of um we
filled it in remember this guy right and
I hope you've still got it somewhere and
I highlighted to you and said why did I
design it with this big empty spot on
the right hand side all the reason is
because I was going to fill it and
that's exactly what I'm gonna do now
please turn over the piece of paper
which I just popped onto your desk now
what you can see here looks like what
you started with last week but I've
typed in a bunch of parts for you the
parts you already wrote in okay so you
start with an original function if you
want to know about stationary points
firstly and I actually did leave
something off so maybe you can add this
back in the first thing you want to do
on the top half is what you want to find
you know much that's right you want to
find out where your stationary points
are right so our word for that was
located okay now to locate a stationary
point of course we're looking for where
the first derivative is equal to zero so
that that top part there we knew
completely how to do that last week but
then after that when we looked at the
second half of this other color the
second half of course was not about
locating the stationary point it's about
once you've located them can you
determine their nature tell me what kind
of stationary points they are right
determine nature last week we basically
said okay well just do some more stuff
with that first derivative right
importantly like a look at a table of
values over here look at whether you're
increasing they're decreasing or vice
versa and then that'll tell you whether
it's a minimum or a maximum or a
horizontal point of inflection but now
we know that there's another way we can
choose instead of going through the
first derivative we can choose which JZ
to go via the second derivative now you
might notice I've skipped a box I'll
come back to that box that I've skipped
in a second but let's just take what we
already know because you actually in
that table we filled out today you can
help me out with this right in the
second derivative what is it that we're
looking for that tells us what kind of a
stationary point it is
if we put some x value like so I said I
found a particular x value I'm like oh
there's a stationary point it's at x
equals two but I don't know what kind of
stationary point it is okay what am I
gonna do with that yeah okay the
concavity tells me whether it's maximum
or minimum the concavity tells me now
sorry I'm just pondering for myself here
we're gonna do an example okay so I'm
just gonna jot down in ya sorry I'm
talking I'm talking and thinking at the
same time okay we're gonna do d squared
Y on D X DX squared I should say and
what we're looking for is whether it's
positive or negative
or zero basically we're looking for its
sign si G n sorry I realized I wrote in
the wrong spot my bad
so we're looking for whether it's
positive or negative or zero okay now
you've got you've got this table right
in front of you okay so have a look at
it right let's just suppose here's our
table right let's suppose we look at
that spot and we're like oh the second
derivative is negative okay what does
that tell you about what kind of
stationary point is second derivative
negative its concave down which means
it's a maximum does that make sense
it's a maximum so if the second
derivative is here we are if the second
derivative is negative I'm gonna end on
the maximum turning point does that make
sense okay
so this dotted line here in the middle
whoopsie-daisy this is what happens if
the second derivative is negative
straight away no table of values
required you're like oh the second
derivative happens to be negative three
BAM I'm done it's gonna be a maximum
okay
by contrast if I find out that the
second derivative has a positive value
like say it's one okay what kind of
stationary point is that it's going to
be a minimum right because it's concave
off which means that you're at the
bottom of that function does that make
sense
concave up so that's a minimum isn't it
so a positive second derivative tells
you you have a minimum over here okay